[Music]
on this sunday night worries of a
thanksgiving coveted spike
the prairie provinces with surging cases
and opposing ideas on restrictions well
human beings are and our behavior are
always the wild card in this while in
alberta doctors face difficult decisions
with pregnant women in the icu
a supply chain nightmare before
christmas season shipping delays will
result in empty shelves the holiday and
everyday items already in short supply
culture clash in quebec businesses at
this moment are concerned the debate
over quebec's proposed language law
divides the province
and a birthday drive-by for a special
centenarian he was in his late 90s still
doing planks every day a second world
war vet says he has a lot to be thankful
for this weekend
[Music]
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight hara nasser
good evening and happy thanksgiving to
you and your family and thank you for
spending part of it with us tonight
it's a time when many of us gather with
family and friends and with it like with
every other long weekend during the
pandemic
comes concern about human behavior
this holiday could it change canada's
kova trajectory and while some places
have looser restrictions experts say
indoor gatherings still bring an
elevated risk
as global's marnie blunt tells us limits
on get-togethers vary from province to
province
one year ago it was the calm before the
storm in manitoba the second wave was
still a concern but kovan 19 cases were
relatively low and few restrictions were
in place when families gathered for the
thanksgiving holiday
then the second wave spiked
plunging the province's health care
system into crisis we had a five-fold
increase in four weeks and then it just
continued to surge from there now weeks
into the fourth wave the majority of
manitobans are double dosed but with
indoor gatherings risks remain
especially for the unvaccinated because
even with this tool
there is potential for pretty
catastrophic situations to occur
when you bring groups of people together
the way this virus spreads is not random
it's looking for every target a reason
why manitoba has restrictions on
unvaccinated groups gathering we were
in a trajectory right now that could
take us to uh to a place where we'll see
quite a significant amount of strain on
our health care system unless we change
it
many other provinces restricting
gatherings to fewer than 30 people or
strictly to immediate families only with
its hospitals overwhelmed alberta
implemented emergency restrictions
prohibiting gatherings among
unvaccinated people altogether please
be careful
please do the right thing
please don't risk the progress that
we've made
over the past couple of weeks one
province over saskatchewan is not adding
in any more restrictions
despite grappling with rising cases and
the lowest provincial vaccination rate
in the country
whether restrictions will be followed or
enforced remains to be seen especially
in areas like southern manitoba where
vaccine uptake remains low human beings
and our behavior are always the wild
card in this
carr also says the more contagious delta
variant and more people delaying getting
tested could influence when we see the
effects of thanksgiving gatherings as
more cases are being identified in the
emergency department and more people go
directly from inpatient to icu patient
pharah
marnie blunt in winnipeg thank you
marnie
and in alberta icu's there's been a
sharp increase in the number of
unvaccinated pregnant women maternity
physicians are desperately doing all
they can to counter the mixed messages
around vaccines as jill crotell reports
compared to the first wave the number of
pregnant women in intensive care has
quadrupled
childbirth isn't meant to happen in the
icu ultrasounds to listen to a baby's
beating heart aren't supposed to happen
with an expectant mom who was
unconscious but frontline workers say
that's happening inside alberta's
hospitals as a growing number of
unvaccinated pregnant women are
hospitalized for severe covet 19
symptoms we need to make this a real
phenomena for people so they'll truly
really think hard about getting the
vaccine even if they're hesitant dr
stephanie cooper has launched her own
education campaign compelled to do
something after having difficult
conversations with her pregnant patients
you're getting sicker they're talking
about the icu
if you go down to the icu and they do en
putting you on a ventilator you'll be
asleep while you're asleep it may be
such that we have to go ahead and
deliver the baby but when you wake up
your baby may be delivered and you may
not be able to see your baby and having
that discussion with a person who's
gasping for breath
and just
it's just awful and they are terrified
there have been 16 pregnant women in the
past couple of months admitted to the
icu some of their physicians say they
have had to make tough choices for mom
and baby this past august five babies
were born pre-term did i make the right
decision delivering a baby prematurely
recognizing the complications of
prematurity that can occur
you know but realizing that i've
delivered that baby because
the intensive care unit managements have
got to the end of their possible
management and this is like the last
resource this new mom was admitted to
hospital with complications from cove at
19 after giving birth to her son bobby
it was a tough decision because being
pregnant i didn't know
like i just thought i made it this long
i
i thought i could make it all the way
through my pregnancy
plan was to
potentially get vaccinated afterwards i
do wish i was vaccinated the hope is in
time that sense of joy of bringing new
life into the world can be restored
jill crotell global news
despite the spike of pregnant patients
in icu's alberta health services is
allowing people infected with kovid 19
into the maternity ward as an essential
or designated support person
ahs says exemptions have been given
since july of 2021 and are granted under
exceptional circumstances those support
persons who are symptomatic or under
isolation after testing positive must
follow protocols while wearing a mask
and remaining two meters from everyone
except the patient and newborn in a
series of tweets ahs says we know the
importance of having support at this
time this is a critical part of our
approach to patient-centered care
while our minds are on thanksgiving
retailers are already concerned about
the upcoming holiday season now if
you've been shopping in stores or online
lately you might have noticed that
everyday items they are becoming harder
to find and the costs are soaring the
reason log jams at ports on both u.s
coasts and too few workers to get the
goods to the store jennifer johnson has
more
a backlog out at sea over 60 container
ships carrying millions of consumer
goods wait to unload at the ports of los
angeles and long beach california the
ships extend 64 kilometers out to sea
but there's a shortage of workers at the
docks and not enough truck drivers to
deliver the goods to stores while the
consumer may be willing to go and spend
more money right now the issue that's
rising is is there actually a product
out there for them to go purchase but
it's more difficult to get what you want
even everyday products are in short
supply across the u.s costco has limited
how much toilet paper bottled water and
cleaning supplies you can buy because of
the port delays
halloween is already turning into a
nightmare for retailers cover 19 stopped
most parties last year this year it's
supply chain issues haunting them we're
still waiting on about 25 or 30 percent
of the merchandise to come in that we've
previously ordered and some of it
probably won't even ever come in before
the holiday christmas is not looking too
jolly either many toys clothing
appliances electronics new cars and now
even artificial trees are getting harder
to find most artificial trees come from
asia where manufacturing slowed to a
trickle during the pandemic now
companies can't keep up with the demand
buy your christmas trees now before
thanksgiving because otherwise the
shelves the shelves will be bad and
there'll be lots of outer stocks retail
canada says stores are reporting the
situation seems to be getting worse as
the year goes on resulting in much
higher prices for consumers skyrocketing
shipping costs are adding to the problem
big retailers are now chartering their
own much more expensive cargo ships but
that's not an option for others a lot of
these smaller publishers and stores are
holding inventory in china trying to
wait out just the freight to see if it
gets cheaper and i don't think this is
going away for at least two years the
canadian toy association says inventory
problems may force some businesses to
cancel pre-holiday sales like black
friday experts say consumers need to be
strategic this season buy early and have
second and third choices in mind
jennifer johnson global news washington
taiwan's president has promised to
protect the island territories democracy
and sovereignty in the face of
increasing aggression from china
made the comments at a ceremony marking
taiwan's national holiday where there
was a rare display of military might tai
vowed to bolster defenses though she
said the territory would not act rashly
and would not bow to pressure the
chinese government denounced her words
as inciting confrontation
on saturday chinese president xi jinping
said he would seek a peaceful
reunification with the territory that's
home to 23 million people beijing
regards taiwan as a breakaway province
and has made international efforts to
isolate the territory in recent days
china has sent an unprecedented number
of military jets into taiwan's defense
zone
and the lights are back on in lebanon
after a 24-hour nationwide blackout
saturday fuel shortages caused the
country's two biggest power stations to
shut down electricity only came back
after the military supplied enough fuel
to bring the grid back online it was
feared the country could be in the dark
for days much of lebanon already endures
daily rolling blackouts because of the
country's aging electrical system
residents who can afford to rely on
generators to power their homes which
has also proved to be a challenge due to
the high price of fuel and the lack of
supply the country has been in the grips
of an economic crisis for the past 18
months the value of its currency has
plunged 90 percent it's estimated half
of lebanon is now living in poverty
in russia high-flying hopes met a tragic
end after a plane carrying a group of
parachute jumpers crashed
16 people were killed in the incident
six others were injured the aircraft
apparently tried to land after its left
engine failed shortly after takeoff but
overturned when it struck a vehicle the
aero club which owns the plane is now
under criminal investigation on
suspected safety violations
a stream of scorching magma in spain the
volcanic eruption in the canary islands
shows no sign of stopping and backlash
over bill 96 why critics say quebec's
language law overhaul is bad for
business and unfair to english speakers
[Music]
in quebec hearings into the province's
new language law bill 96 have wrapped
for weeks dozens of presentations have
been made over what the lago government
says is an effort to defend the french
language in the province but as tim
sargen reports many minority groups and
montreal businesses are still worried
about the law's repercussions on english
the french language minister started the
hearings on september 23rd with a
preamble on the importance of
strengthening french in quebec since
then 39 different presentations were
made over a nine-day period many
defending the majority language but also
trying to make sure english rights and
institutions are protected
we would like the bill to be withdrawn
many anglophone groups fear the bill
will weaken their language rights
including services in health care the
courts and it could erode access to
education at english seizures so many
different items in there that affects
the english-speaking
quebecers and their rights to access to
services bill 96 is a 100-page document
introduced by the minister responsible
for the french language the intent is to
upgrade bill 101 declare french as the
official language of quebec recognize
the nation of quebec as part of its
identity two hundred amendments make up
the bill
montreal's business community has
reservations about the bill michelle
leblanc says there's a critical labor
shortage and he doesn't want companies
constrained with a new language law
where employers would have to justify
hiring a bilingual person to fill a
position businesses at this moment are
concerned
they're a bit scared of what it would
imply protecting english is a major
concern in rural parts of quebec as well
like the eastern townships people living
and working here feel especially
vulnerable if you were sitting in the
seat of
an anglophone especially in a rural
context you feel very very much targeted
defenders of the english language just
hope significant modifications can be
made to the bill before it becomes law
so that this minority language in quebec
can be protected for generations to come
tim sergeant global news
montreal the gruesome murder of a nova
scotia sikh still ahead the fears it was
motivated by hate
you're watching global national
it just keeps going three weeks later
the volcano is still erupting on la
palma in spain's canary islands
officials warn they don't expect it to
end anytime soon
on saturday part of the volcanic cone
collapse sending more rivers of lava
flowing though it hasn't prompted new
evacuations lava has destroyed over 1100
buildings on the island and displaced
about 6 000 people
the murder of a young sick man in nova
scotia last month continues to send
shock waves through the indian canadian
community there
the killing happened in the town of
truro northeast of halifax police have
provided few details about what led to
the attacks leaving some sikhs fearing
the killing was motivated by hate
ross lord reports
prabhjot singh khatri's father died when
he was just six months old he grew up
determined to help support his single
mother working two jobs in true nova
scotia in a fast food restaurant and as
a taxi driver after coming to canada
from india in 2017. he was just very
happy and working um
hard to send money to his mom in india
so she can have a comfortable life which
makes what happened to prabjot singh all
the more shocking
in the early morning hours of september
5th as he left his friend's apartment he
was attacked somebody stabbed him and he
ran upstairs he had enough energy to run
upstairs but then he fell and he died
inside the apartment
friends say he wasn't robbed there was
no obvious motive leading many six to
wonder if his killing was a hate crime
data shows more six have moved to
canadian towns in addition to big cities
leaders in the sikh community say
newcomers are sometimes vulnerable to
hostility and violence there's a lot of
suspicion that
what drove this murder was intolerance
and racism in a statement the high
commission of india said we urge the
canadian government to ensure the safety
of all indian nationals especially the
indian students in canada from racially
motivated crimes the high commission
advised all indian citizens in canada
particularly students to exercise
caution
more than a month after the murder no
one has been charged although officials
in truro promised to pursue every lead
the public was concerned about a hate
and that you know and again there's no
indication at this point that that's
that is the situation but those are
being followed through until they get
answers from police six in nova scotia
are living in fear especially young men
some of whom have told us they're afraid
to appear on camera they don't know what
to make of this murder whether they're
safe
many of them are afraid to go out it
gave a very
bad impression about nova scotia
internationally in in india especially
where six left so we slowly we explained
that this was just one incident police
questioned and released a man they call
a person of interest sources close to
their investigation say they're
currently waiting for the results of
forensic testing before making their
next move
an online fundraiser collected almost
thousand dollars in donations helping
return prabjot to his mother in india
where his body has been cremated
ross lord global news fero nova scotia
over a century on and still going strong
next a canadian veteran enjoys a life
well lived
as canadians gather around the dinner
table to give thanks this weekend an
ontario family is celebrating a life
well lived
sunday marks the 102nd birthday of a man
who defied the odds and gave back to his
country
morgan campbell explains
[Music]
as family friends and wartime reenactors
make their way past graham clap's sasha
home it is easy to see he has a lot to
be grateful for this thanksgiving
one viewer at a time you know when you
get a certain age we don't always get
the next number
looking dapper with a fresh new haircut
the world war ii veteran is celebrating
his 102nd birthday and after speaking to
his family it is easy to see why so many
people have gathered for him he has a
kind soul he is warm and loves a good
laugh he was in his late 90s still doing
planks every day so he is not about to
give up anytime soon he still walks he
gave up driving about a year ago and he
has
a lot of support from from the families
and from his neighbors
on his street
at 102 klapp still enjoys the comforts
of his own home with a live-in caregiver
and he only gave up his driver's license
last year born in south wales the
retired sergeant immigrated to canada 95
years ago in 1926 and later served as a
radio operator at stops across europe in
the canadian army during the second
world war he joined the first special
service force in 1942 nicknamed the
devil's brigade by the germans after 99
days of continuous action
serving alongside a mixture of canadians
and americans clapp was one of 3 600 men
who fought in italy and france today he
is one of only 30 remaining men who wore
the red spearhead of the fssf
still alive it's important to remember
and not to forget
um you know and and appreciate
the freedom the liberty the privileges
everything we have today as a result of
the courage that um these veterans um
have made on on behalf of not just us
you know in canada but the world
the parade is a small token of the
gratitude people have for a man who
inspires others to work hard do what's
right and give back he's just remarkable
that and he's a uh
he just sets the bar really high for the
rest of us to
you know keep on tracking and keep on
going and at 102 years old clap is
showing no signs of slowing down
we all live simple lives
morgan campbell global news
thankful to graham clapp and other
veterans like him and those on this new
front line against covet 19 during this
second pandemic thanksgiving i'm farah
nasser on behalf of our global news
family we are so grateful to you and
your family for not only giving us your
time but also trusting us to bring you
the news every night
tonight's your canada is a chinook arch
in calgary skies on a gorgeous autumn
day we'd love to see your corner of
canada so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other happy thanksgiving
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]